[Music]
now ladies and gentleman to some of you
it probably seems like I've been on
television for a long time especially
our younger fans but there's always more
that I could learn so I got together
with two local broadcast icons Bill
Curtis and Walter Jacobsen at CBS 2 News
at 6:00
I thought what a great opportunity to
sit with them and hone the craft of
broadcasting this is what happened this
is CBS 2 News at 6:00
[Music]
[Applause]
I've come to two great Chicago icons of
broadcasting to ask for help I love to
figure out a way because it's inevitable
that three of us together will do the
news yes do you think that's positively
would you be comfortable with me joining
you as a third for for the next 10-15
years I think we do 15 years yes
increased salary yes okay then very good
tell me what can I do to be like you
guys
well the secret to every anchorman is
that we don't have to wear pants
I noticed that when I came in there's
nothing below oh I thought I can see
that and I've been very impressed with
both of you thank you
look what I can do with my forehead and
also sleep coming useful
when I could use on that really big news
story you gentlemen have terrific voices
do you mind if I hear a few syllables
sweetie he does I'm Twiggy and a little
nasal I don't know I like your voice
don't sell yourself short
you have a nice tone your voice is
golden honey mmm
poured over a corn cob were you born
saying God that or is this actually it's
all that true
I'd like to do some practicing if you
don't mind I'm just reading a prompter
I've had them put up some random copy
who should go first maybe yeah it feels
old first he usually starts why don't
you go Walker and then I'll jump in when
it's my turn okay all I can say is that
my life is pretty plain
I like watchin puddles gotta rein in all
I can do is just pour some tea for two
and speak my point of view but it's not
saying it's not saying it's not that's
the best reading of a Blind Melon
classic I think I've ever heard
thank you for that I'd like to try and
get that on the radio now we need a
sign-off a trademark sign-off that we
use and the three of us are gonna make
anchor history and why don't you precede
it with that's the way it is and then we
do a gesture of some kind would be a
good gesture okay well I would
[Applause]
let's go back let's but I like it I like
your spontaneity and I like your spunk I
think what we should do is all linked
arms at the end and salute let's fight
let's just try it good how are you gonna
link arms and salute it the same tow
you'll see are you ready let's do it
good
that's our news I'm bill Curtis and I'm
Walter Jacobsen I'm Connor O'Brien and
that's the way it is
[Music]
nothing